question de monsieur jean claude mignon
pour le groupe des républicains merci
beaucoup la présidente monsieur le
premier ministre mais chocolat et
monsieur le premier ministre votre
escapade matinale de lundi dernier
n'aura échappé à personne c'était bien
évidemment ni une opération de
communication ni une opération de
reconquête des banlieues comme vous
l'avait dit et comme ça a été relayée
amplement par les médias d'ailleurs n'en
croyons pas un mot et bien évidemment
monsieur le premier ministre je crois
qu'il faut pas non plus oublier et
passer par pertes et profits le travail
important qui a été fait au cours de ces
dernières années notamment grâce à jean
louis borloo
lorsque nous avons créé l' agence de
rénovation urbaine et qui donnent
aujourd'hui tout à fait satisfaction un
certain nombre de quartiers y compris
d'ailleurs dans la ville d'evry nous
étions encore il n'ya pas très longtemps
le mais on a pu constater que vous étiez
accompagné par monsieur jean paul huchon
qui est encore président du conseil
régional d'île de france et président du
stif seul produit quel dommage que vous
ne soyez pas lots aux mureaux avec les
transports en commun que vous auriez pu
véritablement vous rendre compte à quel
point aujourd'hui les conditions les
deux conditions que nous imposons à nos
concitoyens pour se déplacer sont tout à
fait honteuse mais lorsqu'ils ont
rejoint le soir après un multi
difficulté leur commune
ils doivent ensuite emprunter les
transports en commun et notamment des
bus
il s'est passé le 19 octobre dernier à
melun dans ma circonscription quelque
chose inadmissible
encore une fois un bus a été attaqué
attaqué par une vingtaine d'individus et
qui ont caillassé qui ont lapidé
littéralement l'autobus qui s'en sont
pris une fois de plus aux chauffeurs
monsieur le premier ministre je crois
qu'il est grand temps de passer de la
parole aux actes et de faire de montrer
aux françaises et aux français
le laxisme s'est terminée que la
politique de l'excuser c'est terminé et
de faire en sorte que l'uniforme que
portent nos policiers l'uniforme de la
réplique française de la police
nationale soit respectée merci beaucoup
sur le nom
même si la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre madame la présidente
monsieur le député cher jean claude
mignon nous nous connaissons depuis
longtemps mais j'avoue que je ne savais
pas très bien où est ce que vous vouliez
arrivée atterrir en posant votre
question si vous voulez me faire dire
que fossiles concerne la politique de la
ville la rénovation urbaine
il y à une continuité depuis trente ans
je les dis lundi nous le rappelons
régulièrement avec monsieur kader oui il
y à une continuité et d'ailleurs nous
voyons bien sur ces sujets là il y a des
résultats il ya des doutes il y a bien
sûr des attentes et les urgences dans
les quartiers populaires mais il ya une
continuité et je veux j'ai eu l'occasion
mais patrick kanner l'a fait lui-même
ici dans cet hémicycle de saluer
l'engagement de jean louis borloo et
notamment la création de l' agence
nationale de rénovation urbaine et
l'année dernière le président de la
république avait annoncé ces 5 milliards
que nous injection qui en plus seront
que 20 milliards d'investissement
pourront ainsi avoir lieu
5 milliards pour la rénovation urbaine
100 millions d'euros pour les
associations nous l'avions annoncé au
début de l'année pour rétablir des
crédits qui avait été enlevé aux
associations au cours du quinquennat le
précédent bref un travail dans la
continuité parce que nous savons qu'il
faut du temps pour lutter contre les
inégalités à l'école pour recoudre nos
quartiers pour rénover nos espaces
publics pour faire en sorte que l'amp ou
pas l'économie les entreprises
s'implante durablement pour lutter
contre les discriminations et y'a pas
besoin de prendre les transports en
commun ou la voiture pour se rendre
compte de ces réalités que vous et moi
nous connaissons bien et danser réalité
il y a bien sûr la lutte contre
l'insécurité parce que ce sont dans ces
quartiers où il ya de l'échec scolaire
où il ya un chômage plus élevé et
notamment chez les jeunes où une partie
des habitants sont touchés par des
discriminations se rajoutent une autre
inégalité c'est-à-dire l'insécurité avec
le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
bernard cazeneuve c'est pour nous une
priorité
c'est tellement vrai monsieur jean
claude mignon que nous avons
et des zones de sécurité prioritaire
c'est tellement vrai que rien ne peut
être impunis et notamment quand on
s'attaque aux transports en commun
c'est tellement vrai que nous mais je
vous avais pas entendu à l'époque malgré
l'amitié qui nous lie je ne vous ai pas
entendu critiquer les baisses dans la
police et dans la gendarmerie la baisse
du budget de fonctionnement dans la
police nous nous avons augmenté les
moyens pour la police en effectifs et en
moyens et c'est comme ça aussi qu'on
redonne confiance en nos forces de
l'ordre et qu'on lutte contre
l'insécurité
merci monsieur le premier ministre